بعد توقف الملاحه في مضيق البوسفور بشكل
مؤقت نجحت السلطات التركيه في تعويم سفينه
كانت قد جحت الى ساحل بيكوز في شمال مضيق
البوسفورد سفينه الشحن التي ترفع على
مبالاه جناحات في منطقه بيكوز في شمال
مضيق البوسفور في وقت مبكر يوم الاثنين
بحسب السلطات التركيه لم يكن هناك اي
اضرار ماديه او بشريه نتيجه جنوح السفينه
التي تحمل 13 الف طن من البازلاء مركز
تنسيق المشترك في اسطنبول الذي يدير
عمليات اتفاق الحبوب الذي توسطت فيه الامم
المتحده قال ان السفينه كانت متوجهه من
اوكرانيا الى ميناء مرسين التركي على
البحر المتوسط وكانت الدول المعنيه قررت
العمل الماضي تمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الذي يهدف الى تخفيف نقص الغذاء العالمي
من خلال تسهيل الصادرات اوكرانيا الزراعيه
من موانئها الجنوبيه على البحر الاسود
لمده 120 يوما لقنات العربيه والحدث زيدان
زينجلو اسطنبول